und zurückzuführen ist das halt immer
auf das konzept dahinter beziehungsweise
das geschäftsmodell und das von dem
frank rost ist meiner meinung nach
absolut genial ja leute bevor es losgeht
noch ganz kurz ihr werdet merken das
wird heute mal eine etwas andere art von
video
ich hoffe er bleibt trotzdem dran und
wenn ihr sagt macht dazu auf jeden fall
weitere plattform youtube
schreibt mir die super gerne mal und in
dem video beschreibung zeigt sie mit dem
daumen nach oben nachdem video und
schreibt mir die youtuber sehr gerne mal
unten in die kommentare ich bin gespannt
mehr als eine halbe milliarde klicks in
den letzten eineinhalb jahren und über
270 produzierte videos wovon die meisten
mehr als eine million aufrufe erzielt
haben und das mit content den eigentlich
jeder zweite so ganz entspannt selber
von zu hause produzieren könnte ja das
findet statt auf dem youtube-kanal der
prank großmann muss aber auf jeden fall
sagen die zuschauerschaft ist gespalten
auf der einen seite haben wir leute die
feier das extrem ja jedes video wird
total ab gefeiert und auf der anderen
seite gibt es dann diese leute die sich
über jeden kleinen fehler lustig machen
darauf reagieren und es komplett
ausschlachten weil man muss ja ganz klar
sagen das sieht klickst nur was genau
ist das was das phänomen brainbows
auszeichnet und halt diese erfolgreiche
karriere in den letzten eineinhalb
jahren erklärt und welche youtube sind
daran vielleicht gar nicht mal so
unschuldig bei diesem video fühle ich
mich irgendwie so ein
nachrichtensprecher das soll jetzt nicht
so rüber kommen auf jeden fall habe ich
mir diese fragen für das heutige video
bestellt und mit vielen analysen quellen
und form von marketing ein ganz anderes
video erstellt als ihr ist eigentlich
von mir gewohnt seid ihr das habe ich
jetzt abgelesen aber es war ein wirklich
so gut also ich habe hier extrem viele
dinge aufgeschrieben die ich euch jetzt
mal versuche nach zu bringen und zu
erklären
und damit fangen wir auch direkt mal
ganz von vorne aviso schaut eigentlich
gerade die jüngere zielgruppe
anscheinend so gerne die prangt groß
denn auch wenn sie den meisten
statistiken wo es zum beispiel um die
zehn größten deutschen news über geht
gar nicht mehr auftauchen gemessen halt
an abonnenten und nicht an aktuelle
reichweite fallen sie trotzdem in die
top 5 der am best wachsenden kanäle in
youtube deutschland und das bezieht sich
jetzt nur auf private kanäle also kanäle
geführt wie von mir und vielleicht dem
einen oder anderen von euch da auch der
selber youtube videos produziert und
auch die ju zahlen sind wirklich
absolutes top level für youtube
deutschland also ich glaube mir fallen
da wenige kanäle ein die auch mal so
easy 30 millionen user im monat machen
das ist schon extrem groß man kann sagen
die videos sind natürlich sehr einfach
produziert aber vor allem auch sehr
einfach verständlich leute die jetzt
eine große ansprüche einer unterhaltung
haben geben sich damit halte sie mal
zufrieden das kann man auch super im tv
sehen ich meine wenn man mal nachmittags
jetzt um diese uhrzeit bei rtl
einschalten da ist hat niveau ungefähr
gleich bisher selber was hinzukommt die
beiden gehen halt ganz stumpf einfach
immer mit dem trend mit alles was auf
anderen kanälen gut funktioniert wird
meistens dreist kopiert und halt
umgesetzt ich bin mal die letzten 50
videos durchgegangen und man findet halt
wirklich nichts was es nicht schon mal
vorher gab das soll jetzt aber auch gar
nicht zu negativ rüberkommen weil ich
meine man muss das rad ja nicht immer
neu erfinden
ich bin ja auch kein vorzeigebeispiel
dafür dass ich alles komplett mir selber
ausdenken
trotzdem garantiert ist natürlich auch
dass jedes video gut klicks team kann
ich meine alles was gerade im trend ist
wird umgesetzt und trends funktionen
immer gut das war jetzt schon mal zwei
punkte
die sache die ich aber ganz klar als am
stärksten sehe wir haben das schon
gesehen bei heike und romand dennoch ist
schön größe wenn ihr das seht wir haben
es gesehen bei lisa und lena das sind
alles gute beispiele
aber wir haben dann halt auch die print
plus und das sind auch zwillinge die
extrem ähnlich aussehen leute ich muss
mal kurz pausieren also ich habe bis
jetzt immer gedacht dass das tool inge
sind weil die halle komplett gleich
aussehen ich bin mir jetzt gar nicht
mehr so sicher deswegen keine ahnung ob
das stimmt wir sehen auf jeden fall
leicht aus deswegen crypt hat meiner
meinung nach auge zu und das bleibt halt
in den köpfen der menschen hängen der
wiedererkennungswert ist halt viel viel
höher als bei irgendeinem
dahergelaufenen typ der auf seine pause
challenge hochlädt und damit halt nur 50
hughes generiert und der punkt
wiedererkennungswert ist eigentlich so
das ding in der marketingbranche ich
meine alles was eine super
wiedererkennung hat funktioniert auch
gut meine wieder erkennen könnte
anscheinend auch besser sein
vielleicht muss ich mir mal die haare
grün färben oder so man muss halt schon
sagen dass überall auf der welt im
social-media-bereich zwillinge extrem
gut funktionieren ich kann euch jemanden
foto anmeldung von irgendwelchen aus
amerika die gehen halt auch übertrieben
ab ist eigentlich auch schade dass ich
kein zwilling haben eigentlich wollte
ich jetzt hier mit einer
zielgruppenanalyse weitermachen das
problem ist nur ich habe nur die von
instagram von den vorliegenden youtube
zu finden ist halt extrem schwer ich
glaube das geht gar nicht deswegen habe
ich das eher mal rausgelassen aber ich
denke da lege ich nicht falsch wenn ich
sage dass sie schon eine
der junge zuschauerschaft haben was ja
auch nicht schlecht ist nur das wollte
ich kurz mal anmerken ich habe mir am
anfang schon von einer zweiseitigen
zuschauerschaft gesprochen
die ja logischerweise immer dann
entsteht wenn eine person des
öffentlichen lebens polarisiert oder
irgendeinen gegenstand irgendeine
tv-sendung es muss ich unbedingt eine
person die ein leute finden es toll was
die person macht und stehen halt voll
dahinter und die anderen befassen sich
nur mit den themen um sich darüber
lustig zu machen und vielleicht auch um
sich als intelligenter und toller
einzustufen als diese person aber gerade
diese zweiseitige zuschauerschaft ist
der grund weshalb so viel potenzial im
geschäftsmodell der bank brust steckt
das ist wirklich meiner meinung nach ein
richtiges geschäftsmodell viele youtube
ein gutes geschäftsmodell
aber die post haben ein sehr gutes
geschäftsmodell ich meine überlegt doch
mal die laden nennen total bescheuert
ist einfaches schnell produziert ist und
dann auch noch gefällt das video hoch
das ist relativ gut in den trend passt
und irgendwo wald forschung funktioniert
haben wir nehmen jetzt einfach mal als
beispiel das pizza video das ist ja
ziemlich aktuell
das haben wir glaube ich vor einer woche
oder so hochgeladen ich habe genau
dieses video mal vor zwei monaten
gemacht und das kam für meine
verhältnisse gut an und dann haben sich
marvin und calvin gedacht könnte man ja
auch mal machen und ich bin mittlerweile
wirklich der festen überzeugung davon
dass die beiden gar nicht mal so dumm
sind wie viele von euch denken diesen
punkt habe ich in mehreren videos von
denen erkannt und zwar denke ich mal
dass sie schon vor so ein bisschen
überlegen was könnte man tun dass das
video hat extrem polarisiert und die
einfachste methode ist es dann halt
schlecht zu faken weil wenn man sich das
pizza lieferservice video mal anschaut
wo halt irgendwann von den beiden ich
weiß jetzt nicht die einzelnen namen da
offensichtlich den pizzaboten spielen
und das dann auch immer mehr leute
mitbekommen
es wäre überhaupt kein aufwand für die
gewesen wirklich fünf mal bei einem
lieferservice zu bestellen jetzt haben
wir aber hier dieses fertige schlecht
gefakte video was hochgeladen wird und
die zielgruppe der beiden die ja
vermutlich etwas jünger ist habe ich ja
eben schon was zugesagt die schauen sich
das dann natürlich direkt an
und dann muss sagen die schauen sich das
anscheinend auch sehr gerne an und die
feiern dass auch das sind wichtige
vorbilder für die diese beiden ich kann
das ja selber ganz gut nachvollziehen
aus youtube und natürlich ist das
fraglich ob es zeit moralisch in ordnung
ist die ganze
in dem glauben zu lassen dass das was
sie dort sehen wirklich echt ist
aber wenn wir mal ehrlich sind wer von
euch wird das nicht machen wer von euch
wird nicht wenn er die chance dazu hätte
mit so einem video wie sie mehrere
tausend euro zu verdienen ich finde das
aber so schwer da wird doch niemand nein
sagen das video ist jetzt drei stunden
online sagen wann war und es ist bis
jetzt auch wenn es eigentlich absolut
kacke ist wo das kann man jetzt auch
nicht so sagen liegt natürlich im auge
des betrachters aber ich glaube alle
leute die schon ein bisschen weiter
entwickelt sind finden es absolut kacke
es ist aber bis jetzt in der zielgruppe
super angekommen da muss man aber auch
erkennen dass mit der zeit natürlich
auch die ersten kritiker kommen und vor
allem auch die ersten reaktion youtuber
die sich die sache anschauen und
natürlich in der sache ein gefundenes
fressen sehen reaktions videos dazu zu
machen soll es aber auch gar nicht also
ich sehe das nicht negativ ich finde das
super ich gucke mir das auch sehr gerne
aber es ist ja auch wirklich und fakt
dass frank boss videos super
funktionieren so und jetzt fahre ich
weiter fort bei meinem reaktion ich war
sogar ein vortrag das was wir witzig
gefahren weiter fort mit meinem
reaktions video bei dem ich zum beispiel
gemerkt dass alleine durch dieses video
locker 6000 discs auf das video der band
boss gefolgt sind was ihr auf jeden fall
eine krasse wechselwirken ist ich meiner
sind bestimmt von meinem video 60 70.000
leute nochmal drüber gegangen um sich
das bei dem frank boss anzuschauen dann
hat auch noch ungefähr zwei tagen darauf
reagiert und sein video hat mittlerweile
sechs hunderttausend klicks und alles
leute die ebenfalls zum teil zu dem
preis gehen um ihnen dann zu sagen wie
scheiße sie sind summiert man jetzt die
klicks der beiden verschiedenen gruppen
also einmal leute dies feiern und einmal
leute die sich über das maul zerreißen
so haben wir eine riesige klicks
explosion die natürlich auch super ist
für den algorithmus und welche youtuber
hat wird es so viele leute die ihnen auf
der einen seite extrem feiern und auf
der anderen seite immer extrem dauernd
machen also die presse da mein absoluter
vorreiter auf jeden fall zeige ich euch
hier mal meine statistiken zu dem
lieferservice video
wir haben hier 850 dollar für 360.000
klicks was ungefähr 2 euro 50 pro 1000
klicks bedeutet das ist gar nicht mal so
krass stark also als tausender kontakt
preis manchmal habe ich sogar noch eine
bessere cpm aber es ist schon ordentlich
und da liegt die vermutung nahe dass die
post für ihre lieferservice video
ungefähr das gleiche bekommen haben das
heißt wir haben 2700 dollar erzielt mit
einem aufwand von für
vielleicht zwei bis drei stunden maximal
natürlich hat das alles seine vor und
nachteile man muss ja ganz klar sagen
viele unternehmen die interessierten
kooperation sind distanzieren sich von
solcher art von content manche jedoch
auch nicht beispiel sehr aktuell kein
master an der absolut lächerliche app
die aber auch polarisiert und somit
trotz der ganzen kritiker bei der jungen
zielgruppe sicherlich gut funktioniert
weil die hinterfragen kann halt nicht so
viel und downloader sich den schritt
einfach und in diese werbekampagne
passen die post muss man so sagen wie
die faust aufs auge ich könnte jetzt
wirklich noch viel mehr dinge aufzählen
aber ich glaube das reicht fürs erste
abschließend lässt sich aber noch sagen
dass youtube mit meinem business
geworden ist es geht darum zu
unterhalten und manche kanäle laufen gut
manche laufen schlecht manche laufen
mittelmäßig und zurückzuführen ist das
halt immer auf das konzept dahinter
beziehungsweise das geschäftsmodell und
das von dem frank boss ist meiner
meinung nach absolut genial ich bin
hundertprozentig zu euch wäre ich einer
von denen dann würde ich genau so
weitermachen dann sind wir mal ehrlich
wer monat 30 millionen views erzielt da
kann es einfach egal sein ob jetzt das
barclays man mit irgend einem großen
chemiekonzern zustande kommt oder halt
nicht so lässt sich am ende aber auch
noch sagen
der grund warum die post so
funktionieren seid ja natürlich nur hier
auch die ganzen kritiker alle leute die
dir mal so dann machen und die
kommentare hier seid aber scheiße und
die leute die ihren so erwachsenen
freunden davon erzählen was für drecks
videos die priester machen
all das trägt dazu bei das war es
erstmal ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
hat mir sehr gerne nach oben schreibt
youtuber in die kommentare die ich auch
noch so ein bisschen analysieren soll
hat mir sehr viel spaß gemacht ich
studiere auch so marketing-
kommunikations- management- und deswegen
glaube ich dass das mal so ein anderes
format sein könnte was gut auf meinen
kanal passt haut rein check ball ins tor
ab